finally time for the segment that I'm
sure a lot people were waiting for ask
the reviewer we want to get into your
review of the game ten years in the
making my review was ten years in the
making yes the review he's been you just
submitted Draft after draft for the past
ten years there's no copy ten years ago
a super advance copy
all right Pete let's dive into it you
gave it an eight out of ten you like
this game a lot
tell me about it what's good about it
what's good about it uh well let me
start with what I think was
disappointing so I can actually set up
what is really good about it because I
think that's important to understand as
I said the beginning of my review a lot
of Final Fantasy games are remembered
fondly for their story and their
characters I did not find anything in
this game that struck me as memorable or
original or that's surprising like I
feel like I've you know I've seen these
stereotypes before like the you know the
the main cast that you're rolling around
with I've seen villains like we've seen
in in the past and even some of the
events in the game seems somewhat
derivative of our favorite Final Fantasy
games and that's that to me is is is
kind of disappointing like there is sort
of the spectacle of the story missions
and certain boss battles that are these
you know huge bombastic scenes that that
really just showcase what made modern
Final Fantasy games special for I think
a mainstream audience just you know if I
can generalize that way and that stuff
is fun but by the time you're done with
the story yeah I was left thinking like
alright I don't really know that I even
care about what just happened because
what lay ahead of me was a world that I
had felt like I had only just begun to
tap into now the story you can finish in
as little as 10 it's like 12 hours
Japanese players are doing it that fast
right now like hitting level 35 and
being done with the game I spent a
little more time to meet the recommended
level caps and it took me just about 30
hours a little bit more but since then I
have played thirty-five hours just
exploring the world to finish side
quests but not just for the sake of
finishing them but to to in effect grind
so I can get to the high-level stuff
that I found just wandering around the
world like you find crazy difficult
dungeons you find huge monsters and all
you can
think about is man someday I will be
able to get to the bottom of that
dungeon or defeat that monster and see
what I get as a reward or even see what
I am capable of as a player in this
world and it's those pursuits long-term
that kept me going and keep me going I
have two major optional quest lines left
that are promising to give me the best
of everything that I want out of this
world which is equipment and crazy
battles and some of the dungeons I was
looking through a strategy guide today
to solve a mystery that I had been able
to solve up until this point
turns out the solutions someone easy but
the dungeons that I will be seeing are
insane the strategy guide said we can't
explain this to you in text and image
format we've prepared a video because
this dungeon is so hard to interpret and
not not just because it's amazed but
because dimensions angles all these
things you gotta like the fifth
dimension
yeah escape time and space it's nobody
so anyway I just think like this game
has a lot of faults and you know it's
the cliched statement applies it is more
than a sum of its parts like I can
complain about a lot but I can also gush
twice as much about smaller details yeah
we touched on it earlier in the show
we're talking about open-world games
this year and I was saying as someone
who's never played a final fantasy v
they're a Final Fantasy game but it's
gonna jump into it with 15 tonight I
never really think of the open-world
aspects these game because this is like
one of the first time it's been like
just pure sandbox almost sandbox yeah
like the way I define it it's like you
know contemporary open-world principles
or what applied here because a lot of
Final Fantasy games you know apart from
some gatekeeping you do have access to a
massive world and you can go out there
and find towns and some people will give
you these tiny quests but the way that
this game handles it is much more
similar to something you'd see from
Ubisoft right or you know similar Street
publishers James yeah yeah Jake you've
been playing a lot too and you're saying
like you're you've been taking it really
slowly exploring these like these
regions 1-up yeah the console I actually
kind of had a question about the story I
guess do you think you may have liked it
more though if you took it slower
because I'm going slow and I'm finding
out like there's a lot of like side
conversations you have with characters
like do you think you might like the
character
more fewer moving slower because I'm
taking my time and so it's not that I
didn't necessarily like the characters
but I don't think that they are
remarkable in any sense okay
like Prompto for example is a very sort
of like you know uplifting personality
to be around like you know you win a
difficult battle and pop up a bump but
like he sings like the guys I'm Final
Fantasy victory song and that's like
very charming like I you know I like
that and but you know like I look at
Ignace and I look at Gladio specifically
Ignace is oh um British and I wear
glasses so I must be the smart one in
the group you know like like are we
idiots are we supposed to look at that
and say man that's a really clever take
on a character I've never seen before
and now there are times where these
characters get a moment in the spotlight
to show a different side of themselves
but again those don't feel like they
warrant any like serious acclaim from me
so I think like there is some charm to
to gain by spending time with these
characters but by the end of the story
when you've seen everything that they
have to say and they begin repeating
themselves and you've seen all the story
moments that they're involved with
you're left wondering wait a minute they
show me the side of them that I didn't
see before and then it went away then
they went back to the same person they
were and I got nothing new out of them
it just felt like a very fabricated
artificial moment yeah before I actually
came in here I had an interaction with
Prompto it was like at one of the hotels
or whatever and it was like a lot deeper
than normal because normally like you're
saying like we go into a battle and he's
singing or he's like oh this is fun or
whatever but then right after that it's
back in a battle and he's like chipper
again even though he just had this sort
of deep conversation with noctus exactly
yeah it's it's surprising I think when
you look back I'm just I feel like I'm
reiterating so much my review I
apologize
for those who've read it but if you if
you look back at you know like some of
the best characters in the history of
Final Fantasy games were your sidekicks
we're the supporting cast because they
they not only offered something very
different from the main character but
very different from people we know in
the real world right and I feel like so
much what we look at here are
stereotypes you've seen in media and
stereotypes that get that are based on
like real world people in some sense so
that makes sense that's a bit of a
stretch but well yeah after reading a
review and talking you a lot about this
again
this is gonna be my first final fantasy
and I'm pretty excited to try it out but
you said like the first 30 hours or so
or like you said some people are beating
like 15 but probably like 25 30 hours
it's fun because you're going through
the main story you're seeing eos dis
continent yeah but you also said that
like the lake a [ __ ] late game content
these massive bosses these dungeons
these legendary weapons that's where you
had the most fun I believe or where you
had a lot of the fun like can you talk
about that later flike if we stick
around for like 60 70 hours like you did
what can we expect to see so one of the
things you do in the MS story it's an
initiative it's an effort that you start
is you have to go reclaim these weapons
up along to former Kings your
forefathers right and you find five or
six of them throughout the story and
then but if you keep just following it
you can finish the game with only that
many right so that'll leave a whole
bunch you need to find well how do you
get to them or where are they in the
world right so that not only requires a
little bit of digging but it requires
you to I think take the time to do side
quests because you figure out early on
that side quests maybe the goal itself
is kind of trite but the place it takes
you teases you like you'll come across
you'll go fight this little guy and
you're like what's that thing just over
the horizon I've never seen that before
right and it's not until you go into
that side quest you see that really cool
thing so the late games stuff is a
process of finishing the stuff you
didn't do during the story and then
realizing like man this world is more
fascinating than I thought and so these
these endgame dungeons are like most of
the dungeons in the game pitchblack
the only thing that you can see is
whatever is illuminated by your
flashlight or maybe an enemy appears and
the glowing behind their eyes like you
know light up in the dark and it's that
sort of like feeling of this like
daunting adventure and as you improve
and as you begin to beat these big
things that's when I kind of began to
like my team a bit more because it
definitely felt at this point that like
they were my they you know we were
fighting a battle together I didn't care
about their personalities so much as I
valued what they brought into a fight
yeah and that's that's how I found value
in them and I thought that they each
offered something very different so it's
it's both a personal personally
gratifying thing you'll be able to beat
this late-game stuff but also find a way
to actually appreciate the characters
that you're rolling with I do want to
touch on the combat because you said
that was a high point
the game and it looks fun from
everything I've been seen yes what do
you want to touch on of it can you just
I don't know what do you think about
ever people haven't read your review
like how does it work it's always real
time but you're still swapping between
party members if you want to write no no
no oh really
yeah so actually what you saw was you
can use what are they called the special
moves that guess is what they are and
then it swaps that character and you
watch them perform they're sort of like
breaks like you have a meter that has
three bars as your teammates attack and
I think it even builds gradually over
time you can spend certain amounts of
that meter to command your teammates to
do something that's the only control you
have over them in battle
so you'll you know and you can only
control one of those abilities at a time
you can't have a character with multiple
ones right so at any given fight you
have three possible commands to issue
your teammates but that's it otherwise
you're just controlling Noctis and it is
if you you can choose to have not
real-time combat which I'll get to in a
second but for all intents and purposes
its real-time combat you hold down one
button to just do a string of attacks
right there's no real strategy behind
when you attack but you can phase out of
a two phase from an enemy attack so if
they swing at you if you're holding down
square it'll just pass right through you
that and the ability to throw your
weapon and warp to where it is or warp
attack an enemy from a distance that all
cost magic points you have to manage
noctis's magic points because when he
runs out he's in a weakened state so
basically what you're doing this whole
battle is attacking defending at the
right time saving and regenerating magic
points as often as possible
but a lot of the tougher battles you
have to use a lot of items there there
aren't many curative spells in this game
like there are no just plain curative
spells everything is either fire based
lighting based or ice based and you have
to cast that element and then have a
side effect maybe so you use items a lot
to use items you do slow you do stop
combat you press a button and it lets
you go through a menu on the other hand
there's also weight mode which if you
stop moving on the battlefield the
camera will stop and you have lines
between you and the end and the various
enemies on the field and you can take
your time and pick which one you want
you know to target and do something but
that is just so arduous and it totally
like what is fun about combat and
actually you kind of lose what what is
happening in the moment when you stop to
do that kind of sounds like it
sacrifices the flow that ya like
real-time combat sounds like it has
that's the that's the way it felt for me
and I can see that they put it in there
for people who maybe are having
difficulties but there's also an easy
mode which I didn't try but for what I
understand it's basically you can't die
because your teammates can sort of
revive you you have like to death States
one is temporary one is permanent
and so I think your enemies probably or
your allies just revive you at that
point they use much an easy mode I
didn't want to ask I mean it's an RPG so
the more you grind the easier it's gonna
be but what's like the difficulty of
this game overall it's the story mode is
pretty easy up until I'd say the second
to last dungeon if you can call it that
of the story mode which has a lovable
part or suggested level requirement
jumps pretty high it's pretty easy but
when you get into the endgame stuff very
very tough I mean I am expending you
know you find some really like crazy
restorative items in the world and I'm
sitting there like I gotta use this
thing like I've only got two of them
after 60 hours but that party's dying
I'm on my last breath like enemies so
close to death I'll use it and so it
does get very difficult towards the end
and grinding is a thing but even then
I'm fighting enemies like once you get
above level 40 enemies at level 40 will
still be challenging even at level 60 so
yeah it's a hard game this is so much to
talk about I'm sorry I'm oh ya know I've
been rambling through it it sounds huge
and like especially just seeing gameplay
and everything of traveling across this
world I think we're doing a livestream
tomorrow of just like like a road trip
across it or something I have no idea
but it does sound like after 10 years it
was worth away you liked it quite a bit
yeah worth the wait I don't know that
I'd say that maybe 10 years is kind of a
long time but I'll be honest now that
it's here all of that is history I'm
just looking at the game as it is today
I'm not really like I was never
emotionally invested in this game to
begin with I was always just curious
like what is it gonna be so now I see
what it is and what it is is a great
game one that I think doesn't
necessarily live up to the the series
legacy in some ways but it also
reinvents it and does some new things
that it's never done before
well I'm looking forward to playing it
for as my four
final fantasy but if you want to hear
more about it Pete's full review is up
on gamespot he gave it an 8 out of 10 so
go to gamespot.com and check that out
[Music]